there's one mistake i made last year i
am not gonna make it again
uh last year liam i ran out of time
before i got to ask
you a question uh it it it bothered me
very much so i'm going to start with you
this year okay how about that how do you
feel about that
yeah good move dude
yeah oh yeah i had a blunt machete bike
stage you were going to lose a limb if
you didn't
stop glowering at me for god's sake all
right i gotta ask you liam
you have lasted five seasons what is the
secret to
not getting killed on game of thrones
all right let me tell you those two boys
there on the end there have got a sick
sense of humor yeah they're like the uh
you can compare them to the uh the heads
of the five families in new york
right like you get a phone call to go to
dinner
right you don't come back not them
so the trick is don't make eye contact
don't pick up the phone don't pick up
the phone don't make eye contact don't
talk to them
very very wise how would you like to see
davos go
when he goes how would you like to see
him go well i've made a couple of
suggestions i think he should go to
dorne
he should drink some some vintage
dornish wine
in the company of a couple of hookers
and an eight ball